the nation's capital the senate
confirmation of judge katanji brian
jackson was celebrated at the white
house and outside the supreme court on
friday jackson will be the first black
woman to serve on the high court when
she succeeds retiring justice stephen
breyer at the end of his term this
summer jackson whose official portrait
was also unveiled will maintain the
liberal block of the court that has a
six to three conservative majority ahead
of big rulings on voting rights gender
rights and religious liberty
christina raffini is at the white house
with more on this christina good morning
good morning jeff well representation
matters that was the focus of the
celebrations here at the white house
yesterday marking judge jackson's
ascension to the highest bench in
america
it's a powerful thing
when people can see themselves in others
campaign pledge fulfilled president
biden emphasized the historic
significance of the moment we're going
to look back and see this as a moment of
real change the president had promised
if given the chance to nominate a black
woman to the supreme court the first out
of 115 prior appointments i am just the
very lucky first inheritor of the dream
of liberty and justice for all judge
brown jackson thanked her supporters her
family and a higher power
i have to give thanks to god for
delivering me as promised
and for sustaining me throughout this
nomination and confirmation process that
process was contentious no senator i
didn't say verse that's exactly what you
said republicans on the judiciary
committee accused the former public
defender of being soft on crime and an
extremist but in the end they didn't
have the votes to stop her nomination
from going forward and this nomination
is confirmed they confirmed jackson by a
53-47 vote it included republicans mitt
romney susan collins and lisa murkowski
they deserve enormous credit for setting
aside partnership and making it
carefully considered judgment
and vice president harris the first
black woman to hold that job said she
wrote a note to her god daughter during
the confirmation vote and i told her
that i felt such a deep sense
of pride
and joy
and about what this moment
means
for our nation and for her future
and i will tell you her braids are just
a little longer than yours
and when she's sworn in probably later
this summer jackson will join the most
diverse supreme court in history with
four women and three justices of color
michelle
christina thank you